foreign
star Nelson Thomas is facing his biggest
challenge yet I'm not gonna lie I'm
definitely afraid right now but I'm
keeping my composure
on Tuesday the reality star shared
graphic snaps of the injuries he
sustained in a fiery car crash in Austin
on March 5th that's Nelson laying in a
hospital bed with his bloody foot
elevated and Ivy in one arm and a
bandage wrapped around the other and an
oxygen tube in his nose Nelson also
shared these gruesome pics of his
swollen stitched up leg ankle and
forearm alongside a caption that read in
part quote words can't explain how
grateful I am to be alive God is truly
great and he has you in his hands no
matter who you are
grab them
he adds that he is in High Spirits and
getting stronger but has a long road to
recovery you call yourself a champion in
a challenge
it's Priceless
[Music]
the are you the one Alum also took a
moment to thank Minnesota Vikings player
KJ Osborne who was on the scene of the
incident and filmed a video of an Uber
driver and two other people rescuing the
MTV personality from the burning vehicle
noting that they risked their own lives
to save his
do you have a pen
hey can you move your legs
KJ commented on the post writing that he
can't wait to see his friend back up and
doing what he loves Nelson also received
love from his challenge co-stars Corey
Wharton writing love you bro Natalie
negrotti noting that she's praying for
him Devin Walker adding that he's so
happy he's alive while Johnny Bananas
wrote prayers up Nelly here's to a
speedy recovery brother because it's
like spread the love a little bit oh
death grab him
it remains unclear what caused the
accident that totaled the car
hey can you move your legs
[Music]